good morning good afternoon good evening
thank you for joining our luna 4 webinar
today where we will present you how to
get all information from your tissue
sample with less complexity
during this presentation we will
introduce our automated solution to
perform multiplexing imminois to
chemistry assays and special genomic
analysis
my name is sarah milazevik sales
specialist at luna for technologies and
i will be your speaker
today the agenda of our presentation
will be divided in three major parts
first i will present you our
microfluidic technology for tissue
analysis
in a second part we will discuss about
two multiplexing immunofluorescence
assays technique
the tsa based multiplexing if and the
sequential multiplexing if
in the next part i will present you the
erenascop asas
an institute objectization technique
at the end of the presentation a live q
and session will take place i will be
pleased during this time to reply to all
your questions
our company lunaphor technologies is a
swiss film bound with the vision of
bringing omix like an approach to
in-situ tissue analytics for cancer
research
founded in 2014 as a spin-off of epfl we
developed an innovative patented
microfluidic tissue processor to
automate sophisticated assays
we enable comprehensive data extraction
faster than current techniques and
proposed a wide range of application for
both protein and nucleic acid analysis
since the middle of the 90s tissue-based
assays evolved a lot
immunohistochemistry assays that allow
the detection of protein target within
stand in tissue context
is based on an antigen antibody reaction
reri's primary antibodies is the most
critical reagents
immunohistochemistry can be performed in
a single or duplex manner
with a permanent growing need to follow
multiple markers we observed the
emergence of multiplexing
immunofluorescent staining
in addition to although the detection of
a higher number of markers
multiplexing if assays offer the
possibility to quantify the level of
protein expression
in situ hybridization
is very powerful technique used in
clinic as well as in research to detect
nucleic acid targets
the essay is performed with the specific
design probe and visualized using a
bryphene microscope
as the primary antibody is critical for
immunohistochemistry
the design probe is critical for
institutization
institutionalization essay requires the
design of a specific probe but also a
lot of condition adjustments to validate
the use of the probe
from the property design the validation
the quality control of the essay from
the pre-treatment to the stringency
conditions all steps are important to
confirm the specificity of the essay
it requires a strong technical expertise
and several days of work
in 2011 erinoscope technology appears as
a revolutionary technique that brought a
lot of possibilities to support in-situ
improvisation essays
highly sensitive and user-friendly
erenoscope asa allows single cell and
single molecule detection
despite the fact that these techniques
can be run with high throughput automate
they stay for the majority of research
lab performed manually
as i'm sure you know challenges are only
present in research laboratories
performing tissue-based ac
in most laboratories
all essay steps are mainly performed
manually
it increases the sas complexity impacts
experiment due to many potential essay
steps variation
moreover
many novel techniques requires high
precision steps with id controlled
temperature incubation time that are
really hard to control manually
looking for automated solution can also
lead to a lot of complexity
in fact automated instruments available
on the markets are all bulky and
designed to accommodate users performing
standard aces on large patches of sample
in research possibilities are limited
due to the closed nature of most
instruments reagent-wise
it looked obvious then that there is a
need for a tissue basis asa
solution that can be open
flexible
and precise
this is where our technology can support
your needs
we now present you the core of our
innovation
our technology is based on a
microfluidic tip called microfluidic
tissue processor
mtp or just staining chip
the staining tip is composed of a set of
microfluidic channels designed to
deliver and wash reagents on the
vicinity of the sample
the staining chip is simply clamped over
a standard histological glass slide
forming a closed chamber of reaction
over the tissue
reagents are driven into the aromatic
chamber and removed from it by a highly
controlled pressure
thanks to the pressure the liquid
exchange is very rapid and this is why
we called our technology fast fluidic
exchange or ffx
the perfect ceiling between the
osteological glass slide and the
staining chip offers a highly controlled
environment
a heating element is placed below the
slide and allows the precise control of
the temperature at any time as well as
rapid temperature changes thanks to the
limited heat capacity of the assembly
as previously mentioned the active
delivery of reagents through the
hermetic chamber is driven by controlled
pressure
but what is the difference between a
standard antibodies incubation and rfx
technology
to perform a standard tissue incubation
reagents are simply dispensed using a
pipette over the tissue to obtain a good
staining the antibody diffusion is
needed and requires a long incubation
time
indeed interaction between antibodies
and antigen generates a gradient of
antibodies concentration leading to
heterogeneous staining over the tissue
sample
with the ffx technology and thanks to a
continuous and oscillating flow of
antibody and reagents into the aromatic
chamber
we minimize the creation of a gradient
of concentration and we drastically
decrease the incubation time
in order to validate our technology we
worked on a large range of application
first we have demonstrated that
microfluidic-based immunofluorescence
assays with short incubation time can
lead to a great quantification of
fluorescent signal compared to
conventional immunohistochemistry asays
and signal saturation
using our microfluidic technology we
classified ambiguous air to status of
breast carcinomas compared to fish
positive and negative data previously
observed
we demonstrated the ability to perform
extremely rapidly chromogenic and
fluorescent stainings and generate great
data for different markers both on ffpe
and frozen section
we confirmed the preservation of dna and
rna after having performed several
stainings giving us the possibility to
use our symbols for additional studies
like ngs essays
we validated the use of our ffx
technology to run fish analysis
we also confirmed
the capabilities of the ffx technology
to run multiplex if staining using
theramide signal
amplification-based multiplexing essays
in combination with the opel kits from
aquaria
continuously working on usa development
we recently described how it is possible
to integrate our technology with an
image acquisition system to perform
multiplex essays in a sequential fashion
all data in publication are available on
our website but we will be also pleased
to send you the details if required
having the possibility to get a fast
delivery and removal of reagents through
the aromatic chamber
having the possibility to obtain a
homogeneous repartition of reagents and
antibody over the tissue section
and having the possibility to
pricelessly control the temperature will
lead to many advantages
first the most important for every
scientist the high quality of staining
with an unmatched uniformity a very nice
tissue preservation you get a new way of
work with nice and reproducible data
that is always so important in science
working hard to get samples and to do
not keep the best tissue preservation is
always a challenge
but we also know that usually in science
we just need to get it fast
and thanks to our pressure driven
technology we dramatically reduce the
turnaround time required to run tissues
based essays
to perform staining using our ffx
technology we have developed our first
autumn stainer called labsad research
the lab research is a fully open
automated tissue staining platform that
makes the microfluidic-based staining
assays accessible to all researchers
our water stainer contains eight small
volume reagents reservoir 1.5 or 2ml a
band of tubes and 4 larger buffer
solution reservoirs 50 ml falcon tubes
the microfluidic chip and the slides are
inserted and clamped by a handle into
what we call the stainless in the center
of the instrument
the precise volume of reagent delivered
thanks to the pressure is perfectly
controlled by a microfluidic
distribution ship placed on the top of
the instrument
the staining chip is designed for a
single use
the distribution chip can be used for 10
staining are being replaced every day
the lab set is very simple instrument
and was developed specifically with the
goal of fitting the needs of researchers
in fact it is capable to automate a wide
spectrum of non-standard and
sophisticated essays that can be set and
customized via its software
it's fully open and works with any of
the shelf reagents
having seen in detail our microfluidic
solution and our autostainer for tissue
analytics
we will now have an introduction on
multiplexing ifsas
i will present you
first technique to perform multiplexing
i abstaining the teramide asa
signal amplification
followed by sequential
immunofluorescence multiplexing essays
as i previously mentioned the need in
science and clinical above a lot
to develop more precise diagnostic tests
we need to track a higher number of
markers in a spiritual and morphological
context
in the field of immuno-oncology
there is an increasing trend to
understand the complexity of the tumor
microenvironment thanks to the
immunophenotyping
multiplexing immunofluorescence allows
for the detection of multiple antigens
on the same tissue section
it provides colloquialization and
special orientation of proteins which
facilitates an accurate determination of
the target's subcellular localization
identification of multiple cell types
and resolution of the relative proximity
of biomarkers
multiplex immunofluorescence essays
provide information on the expression
levels of biomarkers
while increasing the number of
biomarkers that can be visualized
simultaneously on a single slide
thus the advantage on
multiplexing immunofluorescence aces can
be expressed as better information about
the tissue microenvironment
while conserving the sunburn
immunofluorescence aces can be performed
by direct staining using primary
antibody directly conjugate to a
fluorescence molecule
or indirectly using a couple of primary
and secondary antibody
in basic immunofluorescence stainings
indirect pathway is the most common as
it helps to increase the signal in
particular when the targeted protein is
not much expressed
in multiplexing immunofluorescent
studies the biggest limitation will come
from the fluorescent microscope and
fluorescent molecule were bent
to bypass this limitation the
development of spectral microscopy
opened a new way to perform
immunofluorescent staining
indeed spectral microscopy allows the
good detection of fluorescent molecules
which exhibit another layer of their
emission wavelengths
based on fluorescent properties tsa
multiplexing immunofluorescence use a
set of fluorescent molecules coupled to
thermite radical
sequential immunofluorescence staining
is based on indirect staining but
required a repetition of staining
imaging illusion cycle
during my presentation i will first
focus on the tsa base they say that can
allow you to perform up to six markers
staining plus contour staining
the use of theramide signal
amplification system gsa in multiplexing
immunofluorescence
provide advantages of a traditional
method
the advantages include the ability to
use antibodies from the same species to
detect low abundance proteins
thermite signal amplification uses
australis peroxidase conjugated
secondary antibody and inactive thyromod
fluorophores
the hrp enzyme will catalyze the
conversion of the inactive thyramide
into a reactive radical who will
covalently binds to nearly tyrosine
residues
tsa labeling procedure consists of the
following steps
first
incubation of the primary antibody and
secondary antibody conjugated to hrp
addition of inactivated tyramid
substrate conjugated to a fluorophore
the hrp conjugated to the secondary
antibody catalyzed the conversion of
labeled thyromide into the reactive
radical form that will covalently bind
to nearby tyrosine residue providing
high density labeling
the primary secondary antibody is then
eluted by high temperature
and the second marker
detection is done using the same
principle
to perform the gsa-based multiplexing on
lab site we used the tsa detection kit
from aquaria containing the gsa
fluorophores of different wavelengths
the hrp bound secondary antibodies as
well as the blocking and antibody
diluent
we developed and performed the staining
for six markers plus counterstaining
the development and the optimization of
the tsa multiplex if staining is based
on four points
first the single black staining to
validate every antibody selected
second the uniformity optimization
third the antibody illusion to control
its efficiency as well as the impact of
the treatment on the tissue morphology
and last but not least the multiplexing
stain where we combine all desired
staining sequentially with an illusion
step between each staining
to validate the tsa multiplex training
using our lab site auto stainer we
selecting the following six markers box
p3 pdl1
pd1 cd68 and cd8 to perform the staining
on ffpe human tensive tissue
we will now see in details every step of
the staining optimization
let's start with the singleplex
optimization
for the single plex optimization three
steps are tested the antigen retrieval
treatment
temperature and pressure setting
the reagent incubation temperature
duration and flow optimization
and finally the primary antibodies
concentration and substrate is the
trantation of the antibody and the opal
reagent
for each marker tested we validated the
use of our selected antibodies
we then verified all working conditions
such as antibody concentration
incubation time or antigen retrieval
method
we obtained a signal to background ratio
for all markers
the mean of normalized intensity
presented here were calculated using
three region of interest per slides per
marker
to complete our study we perform
reproducibility studies
using nine slides of ffpe tensile tissue
we observed for all markers less than 15
percent of signal viability
underlining the effective automation of
protocol of the system
we will see now how we validated the
uniformity of our staining
on the signal uniformity aspect we took
the advantage of lapsap active control
of the flow
instead of performing a gradient
incubation we use the dynamic incubation
method constantly refreshing the chamber
content by doing so we decrease the
signal drop from 30 to 60 percent
antibody illusion validation step
the elusion step consists in the removal
of the primary and secondary antibodies
complex from the tissue after each
marker detection
to assess the method we compared signal
obtained from a reference slide and a
slide where we performed an illusion
stepped followed by a staining with the
same secondary antibody
the antibody strip of methods used on
lab sat is high temperature cycle that
provides a very efficient illusion rate
of 99 percent for all antibodies tested
as we can see here on every images
acquired after evolution
let's see now the workflow to perform a
six plaque staining using the lab set
to perform a six black staining using
the lapsed instrument
we created a fully automated staining
protocol for six markers
before running the staining the tissue
is prepared dewaxed and all reservoirs
are loaded with all antibodies and
buffer for the first markers
after the end of the first part of
staining consisting in antigen retrieval
steps blocking staining with primary and
secondary antibodies addition of the
tyramid fluorophore radical and illusion
reagents are swapped and replaced with
reagents needed for the last three
markers
at the end of the protocol the slide is
mounted cover slipped and imaged
taking in consideration the advantages
of the tsa based essay coupled to the
advantages of our lapsed research
instrument
we demonstrated the obtension of really
great data
here we present you data we obtained
from a six plex staining performed in
less than four hours a month
the first region of interest in the left
shows a geminal center close to a
tonsillar crypt
the epithelium is clearly visible thanks
to the detection of panzike in our range
this region of interest also shows a
strong epithelial pgl1 expression in
green
and in the same time a weaker and
punctate pdl1 expression in the
terminals on the macrophages
which demonstrate the ability of the ac
to capture the typical dynamic range of
the marker
the second region of interest focuses on
the region's separating germinal center
there is a dense population of cytotoxic
t cells identified with the membraneuse
expression of cd8 in magenta
another t-cell's population
is well represented here regulatory
t-cell visible thanks to the nuclear
expression of fox p3 in yellow
the region of interest 3 and 4 are
centered on more matured germinal
centers the first one close to a
tonsillar crypt the second a bit further
away
they both show abundant pd1 expression
in science on the membrane of
centrocytes
presence of cd6a positive cells in red
monocytes and macrophages is also
clearly visible in those two region of
interest
to confirm our staining performance we
have validated our immuno-oncologic
panel in different tissue
consisting in pdl-1 cd8 vxp3 cd68 ck and
pd1
here we show you an example of the
protocol performed on tonsils that are
optimized for non-small cell lung
carcinoma
we did some adjustment of the protocol
with the increase of the antigen
retrieval temperature and the
concentration of the opal 540
i will now present you two publications
where the lapsed autostainer was used to
perform tsa multiplexing staining
low-grade endometrial carcinomas ec
are the most frequent genetic ecological
malignancies in europe
after surgery and radio and our
chemotherapy
10 percent of patients progress with
local or distant relapse
currently we are lacking a better
knowledge of pathway that govern tumor
regenesis of
early
low-grade
ec
in this publication lopez janero and his
colleagues addressed the question of
which molecular pathway as disregulated
in easy patients
this is an important point because peace
can support the characterization of
low-grade early stage ec through
quantitative analysis of endometrial
proteome from ffpe
to reply this question they selected two
cohorts of ffpe and fresh frozen section
sample from patients who perform
proteomic studies and pathway analysis
for proteomic studies they performed a
threeplex tsa immunofluorescence
staining for cd8 to follow cytotoxic t
cells marker
cd8 as macrophage marker and cetocaritin
as epithelial marker
in the two representative ic
microphotograph
the observed ir immunofiltrates red and
yellow in tumeral tissue compared to
healthy tissue
the easy micro environment is
characterized by the huge myeloid
infiltration in tumor tissue one
compared to tumor tissue two
the difference absurd for these markers
can support the characterization of low
grade early stage easy through
quantitative analysis of endometrial
proteome from ffpe
the immune suppressive micro-environment
affects efficacity of radioimmunotherapy
in brain metastases
thus the success rate of standard
therapies is limited in brain metastasis
patient
in the publication nielsen and his
collaborators wondering if it could be
possible to combine application of radio
and immunotherapy to modulate tumor
immunity and overcome inhibitory effect
for this purpose they decided to study
the tumor development and detect the
t-cell presence or not
after the identification of t-cells
receptor receptors repertoire and
therapeutic targets they performed
preclinical study on survival and tumor
progression with the combination of
radio immunoterrain the spatial
distribution analysis was performed on
multiplexed staining obtained with
lapsed
here you can see representative allo
special plot on the left panel and
multiplexed immunofluorescence images on
mouse brain metastasis on the right
t cells were stained with cd4 and cd8a
macrophages with cd16 and ebay 1.
tmm110 and ep cam were used as markers
for microglia and epithelial cells
respectively
cd4 cd8t cells were localized closer to
macrophages in brain metastasis this
close proximity suggests that two more
associated microphiliges play a critical
role in regulating g-cell activity in
brain metastasis
we will now see the sequential multiplex
iminofluorescence for iplex protein
study
current challenge in immunofluorescence
for scientists is the need to develop
immunofluorescence panel of 20 plex and
above
performing manually the type of assays
can make the imaging acquisition
intensive and time-consuming
moreover processing one sample each time
requires too much time to obtain all
results
performing a sequential multiplex if for
a huge amount of markers
can be done easily using an automated
imaging acquisition system
that will reduce the user intervention
and the total protocol time
and sample parallelization
to reduce the sa development and the
time to obtain results
as mentioned previously the second
trolling minor fluorescence multiplexing
staining is a great way
to perform this training we developed
our next generation instrument called
comet
our instrument is still under
development
it's all in one staining and emerging
platform that integrates our
microfluidic-based staining with a
fluorescent microscope
it can run extremely rapid eberplex asa
up to 40 plex in a fully automated
fashion with four slides capacity
since it's an open system it allows the
use of label-free off-the-shelf or
custom primary antibodies
it's based on the same ffx technology
with the next generation of microfluidic
staining chip allowing the staining and
the image acquisition without removing
the sample from the stainer
performing multiplex sequential if can
lead to rapid immunostaining every
sequential if cycle consists on the
incubation of two primary antibody
two secondary antibody and conserve
staining with our instrument it can take
10 to 12 minutes
when the staining is finalized this
tissue is scanned through the imaging
window of our microfluidic chip
now the coupling between the staining
chip and the sample is required and the
process is performed in an automated
fashion in data presented here with
before a multiplexing essay can be
performed we need to go through a series
of steps of optimization
our technology allows for playing with
multiple parameters as temperature
incubation times the use of dynamic
incubations to achieve more homogeneous
stainings perform multiple flashes etc
to achieve a good multiplexing
experiment we make sure that we can
remove the signal of every staining in
order to avoid non-specific signal
appearing downstream in the protocol
for this reason every marker goes
through an illusion characterization
step where we make sure that at least 99
percent of the signal is removed
we compare the remaining fluorescence
after allusion to the autofluorescence
of the tissue obtained prior to starting
the optimization procedure
a similar background level indicates an
efficient illusion of secondary activity
from the tissue
subsequently we perform a controlled
staining using only the secondary
antibody and compare the fluorescence
signal with our reference negative
control
the scope of this step is to highlight
any remaining primary antibodies after
the evolution
once every marker in our panel has been
characterized we are ready to create a
multiplexed protocol in the example you
can see here 24 immune markers were
stained on ffpe humantancy
the scanning area was set to four by
four millimeter squares and the total
time of the experiment was five hour
we also used chromogenic reference for
every marker at the benchmark for the
areas we were expecting to see signal
subsequently we transferred our protocol
to sample of non-small lamb carcinomas
and compared again with the chromogenic
gold standard
we know that performing quantitative
comparison between chromogenic and
fluorescence image is not
straightforward
so we came up with two simple image
processing algorithm that will allow us
to determine the area of the tissue that
was stained both
it's widely accepted to employ tensile
samples during the early optimization of
human markers due to the easy access of
this tissue and the abundance of the
expression markers
however this comes with additional
difficulties
very often we need to perform some
re-optimization steps once we transfer
to tissue specific
in some cases only one or a few tissue
types requires adaptation
while in other cases a more general
reoptimization is required
for example this was our approach to
transfer this seven markers panel from
tonsil tissue to colorectal cancer lyme
carcinoma and melanoma
when we attempted the transfer of cd3
and cd4 marker
screening confirmed no need for further
optimization analog and melanoma
we increased the primary and secondary
antibody concentration in colorectal
choice
tissue for optimal results
we will typically look at
you can see here an image we obtain
from a transfer we did from tonsil to
colorectal cancer
obtained with the collaboration of
professor inches lobeck from the
university of bern in switzerland we
have optimized a six plex panel on
corolectal cancer with cd8 cd4 ck cd3
vimantine and e-caderine as a
preliminary steps toward a larger panel
in this case we applied a background
removal algorithm that was developed in
house and that takes into account the
autofluorescence of the tissue acquired
automatically at the beginning of the
essay
images generated with the comment
instrument are exported in omet format
making it possible to import for most
tissue analytic tools
on the left hand side we perform a cell
segmentation using the stardust
algorithm on cue path
then we trained a classifier to
recognize for sp3 positive cells
on the right hand side we used an
ai-based algorithm from allo for cell
segmentation on one of our commit images
after having seen the protein expression
studies via the multiplexing ac we will
now talk about the nucleic acid
detection
the institute hybridization
technology with the eremos cup kit
the arenascope asa is built on doublezed
prop design that allow for single arena
detection at single cell level with
morphological context it's virtually
applicable for any target in any tissue
using universal essay conditions
with the randoscop technology the signal
amplification is really high and the
background is suppressed
the standard target probes consist on a
pool of around 20 double dead probe
targeting a region of 1000 bases on the
targeting rna
each the target proper are designed to
specifically ibidize the target molecule
but not the non-targeted one
each target said probe contains three
elements
the lower region of the zed is a 18 to
25 base region that is complementary to
the target rna
this sequence is selected for target
specific hybridization
and uniform hybridization properties
a spacer sequence then links the two
components of the probe
the upper region of the zed is a 14 base
tail sequence
the two tails from a double z proper
forms a 28 base binding site for the
pre-amplifier
the signal amplification is achieved by
a cascade of ibritization events
first the double set target probes
hebrew dives to the economy targets
then the pre-amplifiers equidistant to
the 20 base binding site formed by each
double z probe
amplifier are then binding to the
multiple binding sites on each
pre-amplifier
the advantages of the arenascope probe
design is
first the sensitivity the detection of
each single rna molecule requires only
three double z probes to bind the rna
target
the specificity
the double z probe design prevents
background noise
and single z probes binding to
non-specific site will not produce a
binding site for the pre-amplifier
there is preventing amplification of
non-specific signal contributing
to specificity
you can see here the workflow to perform
arenas called essay on ffpe samples
using our laplace auto stainer
here is represented all cycle of the
experiment
included pretreatment probabilization
amplification cycles and signal
detection
in gray
are represented all the protocol steps
that cannot be automized on the
microfluidic platform lab set
the full erenoscope asa from
pretreatment to counter staining was
implemented on lab set with the
advantage of robust and reliable
automation
with highly controlled temperature
conditions as well as reduced ends on
time we walked away opportunities to
shorter total procedure time
the arenascope workflow on lab set is
designed to guarantee the minimum
numbers of user's interaction
in the manual tissue preprocessing the
user will initialize the instrument and
load the reagents
labsat will then run a fully automated
protocol
due to limited numbers of reservoirs
users intervention is required to load
the last four reagents needed for the
second part of the protocol
after protocol completion the slide can
retrieve from post processing and
imaging
this will take at least six hours an
half
the erellascope ac was optimized on
lapsad and demonstrated a well-preserved
morphology of ffpe cytological and
histological sample
a uniform staining across the section
detectable punctuated signal dots with
excellent signal-to-background ratio
comparable to the manual ec
the shorter turnaround time with respect
to manual and other automated platform
reduced first
at 6.5 hours and then at 4.5 hours
the ergonoscope 2.5 hd brown
sa automated on laptop for ffpe lsl's
pellet resulted in specific and
reproducible detection
of the tbp positive control probe with
the respect on undetectable negative
control at the bottom panel
being in both cases comparable to the
manual reference as shown in the left
panel
automatization of the eranoscope asa on
laplace also showed an adequate
detection of ppib positive control probe
equal to the manual reference shown in
the upper panel both for the standard
and short panel and multiple ffp blocks
included brain
colon
kidney
liver and spleen
automated renascop 2.5 hd
chromogenic institute hibitization ace
and lapsad were also performed for six
different target probes pd1 pdl1 mk67
fox p3 fgf3 and hpv on values ffpe human
tissue tonsil breast cancer colon cancer
and cervical
for all results we observed adequate
detection of multiple target probes for
standard and short neuron comparable to
manual staining
in the calculation of the time the
paraffinization and bluing mounting is
not included
in conclusion a power rna aceron in
lapsad we observed and proved the
capability of our instrument to automate
the erynoscope ac we observed a very
well preserved morphology of ffpe
psychological and histological samples a
uniform staining across the section and
a readily detectable pointed signal dots
with excellent signal-to-background
ratio
the lapsed platform brings the benefits
of shorter run time and highly
reproducible method in a compact device
with a very highly controlled
temperature conditions
shorter turnaround time with respect to
manual and other automated platform
and the reddish hands on time and walk
away opportunities
laptop research provides a simple and
affordable benchtop automation solution
for sophisticated assays like arenascope
rendering it into a faster easier and
highly reliable method
now let's go for the conclusion and
outlook of our presentation
in conclusion and take home messages of
our presentation
we first described the potential of our
lab site research instrument to perform
automated staining in one single
platform to do co-detection aces of
proteins and genomics
we are always looking to work with new
partners to further develop techniques
so please do not hesitate to contact me
if you are interested
we also developed the potential of our
next generation instrument comet to
perform high throughput iplex sustaining
it's now time for our q any session
please submit your question i will be
pleased to answer it